what is seven hundreds times ten
well let's focus first on this times ten
part of our expression
because multiplying by ten has some
patterns in math that we can use to help
us solve
one pattern we can think of when we
multiply by 10 is if we take a whole
number and multiply it by 10
we'll simply add a 0
to the end of our whole number
so for example if we have a whole number
like 9
and we multiply by 10
our solution will be a 9
with 1 0 at the end or 90
because 9 times ten is the same as nine
tens and nine tens is ninety
so let's use that pattern first
to try to solve here we have seven
hundreds so seven times we have a
hundred or seven hundred
and we're multiplying again times ten
use this pattern over here our solution
will add a zero at the end
so if we had seven hundred ten times we
would have seven
hundred with a zero on the end or seven
thousand
so seven hundreds times ten is equal to
seven thousand
but there's another pattern we could use
here
another pattern to think about when we
multiply by 10
and that is that we multiply by 10 we
move every digit
one place value one place value
left
or one place value greater
so let's look at that one on a place
value chart
here we have a place value chart to use
that earlier example when we had nine
ones
and we multiplied it by ten
our nine moved one place value to the
left it moved up to the tens now we had
nine tens
and we filled in a zero here because
there were no ones left there were zero
ones left
and so we saw that nine
times ten
was equal
to ninety
so again it's the same as adding a 0 at
the end but we're looking at it another
way we're looking at in terms of place
value and multiplying by 10 moved every
digit one place value to the left
so if we do that with the same question
700
700 if we move hundreds one place value
to the left
we'll end up with thousands so 700 times
10
is 7
thousands
or as we saw earlier seven
thousand so either one of these
is a correct answer
seven hundred times ten is 7 000.
and here's an example with division now
we have dividing by 10
and as you might predict dividing by 10
is the opposite of multiplying by 10 so
our patterns are also the opposite
instead of adding a zero to the end of a
whole number
we would drop a zero at the end
we would drop a zero at the end
so for an example if we had 40
divided by 10
we would drop that zero and end up with
four
if you divide 40 into groups of 10
you have four groups
let's use that over here 210 or 212 tens
so we have 212
tens
so 212 10 times it's how we got the zero
there
and we divide that by ten
we can use this first pattern we thought
of and just drop the zero on the end
let's drop that zero
and our answer will be two hundred
twelve
but we could also we could use the place
value pattern we could think in terms of
place value
and instead
of moving
one place value to the left one place
value larger we're going to move one
place value smart smaller or to the
right
one place value to the right
so what's one place value smaller than
212 tens if we have 212 tens divided by
10
we want to move this tens one place
value to the right or smaller which is
ones so our solution
would be 212
ones
which is equal to what we already saw
simply 212. so 212 tens divided by 10
we could write the number out and drop a
zero
or we could think about place value and
move one place value to the right either
way our answer is 212 ones